[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend Ihnen dieses Land wendet
sich bzw es soll sich wenden
Verkehrswende Energiewende und jetzt
dazu die wärmewende was da heute in der
Bundesregierung auf den Weg gebracht
wurde ist ein ganzes Gesetzespaket das
Einsparungen bringen soll Effizienz
Klimaneutralität und grünen Strom alles
auf einmal
der Strom steht im Mittelpunkt an ihm
hängt die Verkehrswende an ihm hängt
auch die wärmewende in 8 Jahren sollen
80% des Stromverbrauchs von erneuerbaren
Energien geliefert werden und zwar auch
an Wärmepumpen in den Häusern als
Alternative zu Öl und Gas die Regierung
will sechs Millionen Wärmepumpen
schaffen in den kommenden Jahren im
letzten Jahr waren es gerade mal 150.000
gehorchheit jetzt über Vorteile und
Hürden
auf diesem ehemaligen Bauernhof bei
Bergkamen am Rande des Ruhrgebiets wird
mit Strom geheizt mit Strom und diesem
Kasten eine Wärmepumpe die den Strom
möglichst effektiv in Wärme umwandelt
Katharina Potratz und ihr Mann an Trick
kneipel haben die Entscheidung vor
zweieinhalb Jahren für eine Wärmepumpe
nicht bereut im Gegenteil
die Heizung läuft bei uns tadellos wir
haben nicht gefroren obwohl wir 2021 den
großen Schnee hier bei uns hatten wo wir
auch minus 20 Grad bei uns hier als
Außentemperatur hatten und von daher
muss ich sagen sind wir vollends
zufrieden damit ja
eine Wärmepumpe nimmt die
Umgebungstemperatur auf
verdichtet sie mit Hilfe des
elektrischen Stroms auf höhere
Temperaturen und gibt diese Wärme dann
an die Heizung ab eine Wärmepumpe sollte
mit möglichst wenig Strom möglichst viel
Heizungswärme erzeugen wenn der Strom
aus erneuerbaren Energien stammt ist das
klimaneutral
so eine Anlage ist nicht ganz billig
zusammen mit dem Kessel und allen
Leitungen hat Familie podratz kneipel
rund 27.000 Euro in ihre neue Heizanlage
gesteckt zusätzlich zahlte der Staat
rund 22.000 Euro an Förderung
49.000 Euro sind das zusammen
die Familie hat außerdem gedämmt und
weitere Fußbodenheizungen eingebaut für
einen ähnlichen Betrag denn je weniger
gedämmt ist und je weniger
Flächenheizungen genutzt werden desto
mehr Strom verbraucht eine Wärmepumpe
das Wirtschaftsministerium will ab
Januar 2024 auch in Bestandsgebäuden nur
noch neue Heizungen erlauben die
größtenteils mit erneuerbaren Energien
betrieben werden statt eines Interviews
schreibt das Ministerium
die Wärmeversorgung von Gebäuden muss in
Zukunft klimaneutral energieeffizient
und technologieoffen auf Basis
erneuerbarer Energien erfolgen natürlich
müssen wir auch bei den Bestandsbauten
Heizungen austauschen nur mit
energetisch-effektiven Heizungen im
Neubau ist das nicht schaffbar
auch für Familie pro tratz kneipel war
die Umstellung aufwendig man braucht
Geld eine gute Planung mit einem
Energieberater das richtige Gerät und
den richtigen Installateur eine
Wärmepumpe reagiert sehr sensibel auf
Planungs- und Ausführungsfehler
wir wissen aus Aussagen des
Zentralverbandes sanitärheizung Klima
das momentan nur ein Drittel der
Installationsbetriebe überhaupt in der
Lage sind qualifiziert eine Wärmepumpe
zu planen und einzubauen und parallel
dazu kommt noch der massive
Fachkräftemangel es fehlen ja mehrere
tausend Fachkräfte überhaupt und es
mangelt im Moment an notwendiger
Qualifizierung und deswegen bin ich
skeptisch ob das gelingt quasi ab 24
mehr oder weniger aus dem Stand nur noch
überwiegend Wärmepumpen einzubauen in
Bergkamen hat es geklappt mit der
Wärmepumpe und sie ist auch nicht
sonderlich laut
was ja auch noch so ein Aspekt ist
das stimmt lamiya messarie Becker ist
Professorin für Gebäudetechnologie an
der Uni Siegen und jetzt bei uns Frau
Professorin guten Abend guten Abend
150.000 Wärmepumpen ich habe es vorhin
schon gesagt sind in Deutschland im
letzten Jahr eingebaut worden bis 2030
sollen es 6 Millionen sein ist das
realistisch oder ist das einfach
Fantasiezahlen Gespinst der Politik es
ist deshalb nicht realistisch weil der
Ausgangspunkt der dass wir in der
wärmewende gerade mal 15% erneuerbare
Energien haben also der Anteil an
erneuerbare Wärme bei Gebäude ist nur 15
Prozent das heißt die Ziele müssen zwar
ambitioniert sein aber die sind sehr
selten mit der Realität zurückgekoppelt
wir haben zu wenig Fachkräfte wir haben
auch Einbau und
Produktionskapazitäten Störung der
Lieferketten all das führt dazu das ist
kaum machbar ist und zudem haben wir die
Situation das natürlich der Bestand
nicht immer sich eignet für eine
Wärmepumpe das muss noch sehr viel im
Vorfeld passieren damit eine Wärmepumpe
tatsächlich auch funktioniert okay da
fangen wir mit dem letzten vielleicht
mal an bevor wir auf Fachkräftemangel
kommen bestand und das was tatsächlich
dann Neubau ist das ist einfacher wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe warum
ist der Bestand also sprich das
Nachrüsten so kompliziert das liegt
daran dass der Heizwärmebedarf natürlich
bei ungedämmten Gebäuden im Altbau sehr
hoch ist und eine Wärmepumpe hat es
immer leichter ein Gebäude zu heizen
wenn der die Temperaturdifferenz
zwischen Außen- und innen gering ist und
gerade im Winter wenn es im
Minustemperaturen gibt schafft sie das
aus eigener Leistung nicht mehr und
zieht dann Strom vom letzten dann kann
es sehr teuer werden bzw es kommt dann
auch darauf an dass wir erneuerbaren
Strom dafür nutzen wichtig ist auch zu
unterscheiden dass wir Wärmepumpen
Unterschiede haben je nachdem ob sie der
Luft oder dem Grundwasser oder der
Erdwärme Luft Energie entzieht und
entsprechend hat hier die Politik leider
sehr lange eine wärmewende verhindert
und hat beispielsweise Geothermie
überhaupt nicht gefördert wie Beispiel
beispielsweise andere Technologien jetzt
versucht die Politik eine wärmewende und
zwar mit Karacho kann man vielleicht
sagen sie sagen ambitionierte Ziele sind
gut sind wichtig aber die Politik wird
sie nicht erreichen weil die Leute
fehlen die das umsetzen sollen jetzt
wundert man sich so ein bisschen weil
bei den bei den Terminen der Politik
sitzen Unternehmen Verbände ja alle mit
am Tisch sind die nicht genug
eingebunden trotzdem oder warum fehlt es
an so vielen Menschen die am Ende das
dann auch einbauen die sind jedenfalls
nicht früh genug eingebunden worden denn
die Klimaschutzziele werden ja sehr oft
auch einseitig definiert von
Umweltverbänden von Menschen die mehr
Klimaschutz verlangen allerdings nimmt
man zu spät erst die Fachkräfte dazu die
Ingenieure dazu die Industriebetriebe
die das Stimmen sollen wir müssen auch
beachten dass in Deutschland dieses
Gewerk Klima Heizung Sanitär klein bis
mittelständig geprägt ist das heißt wir
reden dort über Unternehmen die haben
vielleicht zwei bis 20 Leute das sind
keine Unternehmen die relativ schnell
auf solche Veränderungen reagieren wir
brauchen also mehr Personal mehr
Weiterbildung und langfristige
Investitionspläne damit Sie auch
tatsächlich mitgehen können mit all
diesen Problemen was würden Sie sagen
ist das wenn das Ziel nicht erreichbar
ist ist die Hälfte erreichbar oder nur
ein Viertel geben Sie uns doch da mal
eine Einschätzung bitte ich würde sagen
dass vielleicht ein Drittel der
Bestandsgebäude innerhalb von zehn
Jahren auf dem Niveau zu bringen wäre
allerdings müssen wir auch Technologie
offen sein das wurde ja im Beitrag
angesprochen die Realität ist eine
andere man fördert nur eine Technologie
nämlich überwiegend die Wärmepumpe in
diesen Zeiten sollte man eigentlich alle
Technologien nutzen wie oft hier auch
zitiert wird jede Kilowattstunde zählt
jede Technologie würde ich auch sagen
zählt ungenutzt ist in diesen Zeiten
unentschuldbar gehen und Bürger dieses
Landes den Ernst der Lage tatsächlich
verstehen welche Hilfe bräuchten sie
denn jetzt vom Staat hören wir denkt
dass so eine Wärmepumpe um die 30.000
Euro kostet da gibt es jetzt bereits
eine enorme Förderung aber was wäre aus
ihrer Sicht noch nötig also kurzfristig
müssen wir insbesondere auf kleine
Maßnahmen schauen Maßnahmen die darauf
hinauslaufen dass die bestehenden
Heizungsanlagen optimiert werden dass
Heizungsrohre gedämmt werden dass wir
Heizungsanlagen richtig einstellen dass
wir vielleicht auch Dämmung von
unausgebauten Dachboden fördern
organisatorisch und unbürokratisch da da
ist einfach noch sehr viel zu tun wir
fördern immer die großen Maßnahmen die
großen Maßnahmen brauchen aber mehr
Material mehr Fachkräfte der Fokus
sollte jetzt auch mal auf die kleinen
Maßnahmen fördern liegen und wir müssen
Technologien wie Geothermie wie
biogas-blockheizkraftwerke etc auch mit
in den Blick nehmen mit fördern das ist
bisher nicht passiert der Appell von
einer Expertin für Bau und Energie Frau
Professorin vielen Dank für Ihren Besuch
heute bei uns hier im Studium
ja und der Präsident des Verbandes
kommunaler Unternehmen fordert jetzt
einen Schutzschirm des Bundes für alle
Stadtwerke in der Gaskrise mehr dazu
nachher im heute schon mal Update mit
dem Kollegen Wolf schmiese
unser nächstes Thema heute abend Boris
Johnson kämpft um seinen politisches
Überleben diese Schlagzeile kommt ihnen
vielleicht bekannt vor der britische
Premier hat eine lange Reihe von
Skandalen R und überlebt heute abend
heißt es jetzt aus London Johnson Kämpfe
ums politische Überleben so stark wie
nie zuvor die Kameras sind jetzt
gerichtet auf diese Tür number ten
Downing Street das sind Live Bilder aus
London dahinter kämpft der
Premierminister mit einer schweren
Regierungskrise hintergrund ist eine
ganze rücktrittswelle der eigenen Leute
verbunden mit heftiger Kritik an Johnson
unter anderem werfen jetzt der Finanz
und der Gesundheitsminister hin wir
gehen live nach London zu Andreas Stamm
Andreas guten Abend was ist denn den
beiden jetzt plötzlich am Führungsstil
ihres premiers aufgefallen negativ
ich glaube dass der Führungsstil dieses
Premierministers unter aller Würde war
das ist vielen schon aufgefallen auch in
Boris Johnsons eigener Partei aber der
der das Tropfen der das Fass zum
Überlaufen gebracht hat war ein erneuter
Sexskandal dort hat der deputin Chip das
ist sozusagen ja der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende und diese Web das
heißt ja auch schon was die Peitschen
ein der hat sich ja an an Männern
vergriffen und dann hieß es erstmal
Johnson weiß davon wusste davon nicht
als er ihn zum in diesem Posten gehoben
hat und dann wurde aber sehr schnell
klar dass er wieder einmal gelogen hat
und das hat eben nun das Fass zum
Überlaufen gebracht das ist ja wirklich
wie du sagst eine Reihe von Skandalen
Korruption dann partygate also wirklich
während der corona-krise in seinem
Amtssitz wurden Partys gefeiert und ist
der erste premier der dafür mit einer
Strafe zu einer Strafe verurteilt wurde
zu einer Geldstrafe und sozusagen als
verurteilter im Amt sitzt und ich glaube
jetzt ist es dieser Partei einfach zu
bunt denn die ganze mangelt es eben an
jemanden der sagt okay wir müssen jetzt
diesen Königsmord diesen politischen
Königsmord eben vollziehen und ich
glaube dieses dieser Prozess der hat
jetzt gerade stattgefunden in dem der
Finanzminister und der
Gesundheitsminister also zwei der ja von
den fünf wichtigsten Ministern einfach
gesagt haben so jetzt ist Schluss und
dass er das Überleben kann das glauben
nur die wenigsten auch wenn Boris
Johnson natürlich ein Überlebenskünstler
ist ja ein politisches Stehaufmännchen
so kennen wir ihn ja eben auch in den
letzten Jahren ist wie geht es denn
jetzt einfach konkret weiter in der
Politik auf der Insel
ja er wird jetzt versuchen diese Lücken
zu füllen mit ihm Getreuen die gibt es
natürlich durchaus noch aber er hat ja
erst ein Misstrauensvotum seiner Partei
überstanden das heißt dann normalerweise
dass er ein Jahr erstmal sicher im Amt
ist aber es gibt eben schon Bestrebungen
die Regeln zu ändern dass man in erneut
einen Misstrauensvotum seiner
Parlamentsfraktion aussetzen kann und
ich glaube daran wird jetzt hinter den
Kulissen fleißig gearbeitet und das ist
eben der Machtkampf er kann nicht zum
Rücktritt gezwungen werden er kann eben
nur abgewählt werden durch dieses ja
Misstrauensvotum und das muss jetzt
erstmal geregelt werden damit jetzt
hinter den Kulissen viel geschoben aber
es gibt eben dieses Gefühl dass
normalerweise wenn so wichtige Minister
denn der Premierminister ist nur ein
Primus interpares erst einer eingebunden
in diese kabinettsdisziplin wenn zwei
ist derart wichtige Minister
zurücktreten dann ist das das Anfang vom
Ende und wie man so schön sagt Rom fällt
wohl jetzt
Andreas Stamm live aus seinem typisch
britischen Arbeitszimmer in London
herzlichen Dank und mit der aktuellen
Situation in den Kriegsgebieten in der
Ukraine beginnst du jetzt Hanna und da
haben sich die Kämpfe in die Region
dunjetsk verlagert wo sich die Lage
aktuell deutlich verschärft und nun
350.000 Menschen zur Flucht aufgerufen
wurden massiven Beschuss gab es unter
anderem in der Stadt slovianz im
Bürgermeister zur Folge richtete sich
der Angriff Russlands gegen den
zentralen Markt der Stadt slovianz gilt
als nächstes Ziel der russischen Truppen
auf ihrem Vormarsch im Donbass
während in der Ukraine also die
Zerstörung weitergeht wurden in Lugano
in der Schweiz bereits die Weichen für
den Wiederaufbau des Landes gestellt und
40 Länder und Organisationen haben ihre
Unterstützung zugesagt und außerdem
Prinzipien aufgestellt wieder
Wiederaufbau organisiert werden soll
etwa um Korruption vorzubeugen die
ukrainische Regierung schätzt die Kosten
dafür auf über 700 Milliarden Euro
die corona-zahlen steigen mit deutlichen
Konsequenzen für die Krankenhäuser denn
immer mehr personalfeld deshalb aus im
ganzen Land müssen wegen des
Personalmangels einzelne Stationen
Schließen der Vorstandschef der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft Gas
zeigte sich besorgt dass die Versorgung
nicht mehr im gewohnten Maße
sichergestellt werden können dies sei
ein schweres Versäumnis der Politik
der umstrittene Frankfurter
Oberbürgermeister Peter Feldmann hat
angekündigt Ende Januar 2023
zurückzutreten gegen den SPD-Politiker
läuft ein Verfahren wegen
Korruptionsverdachts der 63-Jährige
sagte er wolle der Stadt ein quälendes
und teures Abwahlverfahren ersparen und
seine Amtsgeschäfte zu einem
ordentlichen Abschluss bringen fällt man
ist wegen des Verdachts der vorteilsname
angeklagt so soll seine Frau als
Leiterin einer AWO-Kita ohne sachlichen
Grund ein übertarifliches Gehalt bezogen
haben
nach dem tödlichen Angriff eines
Schützen auf eine Parade zum
us-nationalfeiertag hat die Polizei
einen Verdächtigen festgenommen der
21-Jährige wurde nach stundenlanger
Suche und einer Verfolgungsjagd gefasst
in Highland Park einem Vorort von
Chicago hatte der Täter vom Dach eines
Gebäudes in die Menschenmenge gefeuert
und das mit einem legal erworbenen
Sturmgewehr sechs Menschen starben über
30 wurden verletzt darunter auch Kinder
das Motiv ist weiterhin unklar
der mit Sicherheit bekannteste
Botschafter in Deutschland wird wohl
bald Abschied nehmen andere Melnik
Vertreter der Ukraine bei uns wird nach
Hause befördert ins Außenministerium
nach Kiew meldet die Bild-Zeitung
offiziell ist das nicht bestätigt im
Berliner Regierungsviertel dürften
Seufzer der Erleichterung dennoch schon
zur höheren sein denn Melnik ist einer
der von klassischer Diplomatie nicht
viel hält angesichts des Krieges in
seiner Heimat viel er mit scharfer oft
polemischer manchmal auch beleidigender
Kritik an der Bundesregierung auf aber
er fiel auf
zuletzt hat der Botschafter selbst viel
Kritik einstecken müssen weil er einen
ukrainischen nationalistenführer
verteidigte und verharmloste der in der
Ukraine selbst umstritten ist Stepan
banderdera war während des Zweiten
Weltkriegs politisch verantwortlich für
eine radikale Organisation deren
Einheiten zehntausende polnische und
jüdische Zivilisten vertrieben und
ermordeten derselbe bandera gilt
speziell im Westen der Ukraine rund um
Lemberg fielen als freiheits-
hier wird nur eingelassen wer die Losung
kennt aber sie ist denkbar einfach Slava
Ukraine
die Gries gab war in Lemberg hat den
ukrainischen Partisanenkrieg zum Konzept
gemacht Ukraine ist unsere Mutter unser
Vater ist Mandara lautet der Refrain des
Liedes
ehrlich gesagt konzentrieren wir uns gar
nicht nur auf bandera oder auf andere
ukrainische nationale Führer aber unsere
Bar vermittelt Informationen wie
ukrainische Partisanen damals gelebt und
gekämpft haben
in der zugehörigen Souvenir Geschäft ist
bandera der Bestseller sein Konterfei
omnipräsent großen nun jede Nation
braucht seine Helden und bandera als
Symbol er kann das bewirken
im Rücken des bandera-denkmals in
Lemberg treffen wir Rost die Slav er hat
die Schule beendet und ist 19 und
wehrpflichtig dann wäre es für ihn kein
Idol
viele in meinem Alter bewundern wie er
gegen die Russen gekämpft hat sie wissen
nicht alles bandera hat auch schlimme
Dinge gemacht
Banderas Ziel war ein unabhängiger
ukrainischer Staat aber auch ein
ethnisch gesäuberter den er mit allen
Mitteln gründen wollte auch mit
faschistischen er hat progrome gegen
Polen und Juden initiiert seine Anhänger
töteten fast 10000 Polen wirkten bei der
Deportation von hunderttausenden Juden
durch deutsche Nationalsozialisten mit
pandera war ein kleiner Nationalist und
eine kleine Faschist der ein der der
Führer auf Ukrainisch profitnik eines
ukrainische faschistischen Staates
werden wollte dieser Staat wurde im Juni
41 programmiert aber Hitler hat diesen
Stadt nicht anerkannt der Plan ist
gescheitert
bandera habe zur Zeit der grolltaten im
KZ Sachsenhausen eingesessen und im
Gegensatz zu Hitler und Stalin für
Historiker nur weniger eigene Texte
hinterlassen sagt Professor kretscher
das Hauptziel von bandera war die
Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine er versuchte
sie mit allen Mitteln zu erreichen und
wenn er dafür Faschismus einsetzen
musste dann setzte er Faschismus ein
vor der russischen Invasion war bandera
in der Ukraine umstritten eine
Kontroverse Figur jetzt hat sich der
Blick vieler Ukraine geändert
was ich sagen kann hier in der Ukraine
steht bei derer jetzt fast
ausschließlich als ein Symbol für den
Widerstand gegen Russland der Krieg hat
vieles in der Ukraine verändert auch den
Umgang mit bandera die Zeit dies
aufzuarbeiten wird kommen nach dem Krieg
[Musik]
Finnland und Schweden sind der NATO
heute einen weiteren Schritt näher
gekommen aber sie sind noch nicht da
heute wurden zwar die sogenannten
beitrittsprotokolle unterzeichnet und
zwar auch von der Türkei aber die
Vereinbarung mit Präsident recept type
Erdogan wackelt bereits wieder offenbar
haben beide Seiten damit voller Kraft
aneinander vorbeigeredet jedenfalls
stellt sich immer mehr heraus dass sich
die Türkei ihr ja zum NATO-Beitritt der
nordischen Länder teuer hat abkaufen
lassen zumindest wenn man der Lesart des
türkischen Präsidenten folgt Florian
neuhahn mit mehr dazu
während sie in Brüssel am Vormittag
manche Krawatte zurechtrücken dann
gemeinsam den beiden nato-anwärtern aus
dem Norden applaudieren schließlich von
einem historischen Tag sprechen bekommt
Bülent kenne ich in Stockholm etwas
Angst droht die Auslieferung in die
Türkei und dort lebenslange Haft
mich folgen
sie mich vor ein paar Wochen vor diesem
falschen gefragt hätte ich gesagt ich
habe überhaupt keine Sorge keinen
Verdacht aber seit Erdogan diese
Verhandlung um die NATO-Mitgliedschaft
für seine Zwecke nutzt kann ich mir
nicht mehr zu 100 Prozent sicher sein
[Musik]
in der Türkei war kinesisch
Chefredakteur einer regimekritischen
Zeitung Anhänger der gülenbewegung die
vom türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan
verfolgt wird 2016 Flo er nach Schweden
ist selbst kein lupenreiner Demokrat
aber nach europäischen Maßstäben kein
Terrorist
das Erdogan das anders sieht dürfte
nicht überraschen dass er unter anderem
diesen Fall nun zum Spielball der
Weltpolitik macht aber auch nicht denn
NATO-Gipfel in Madrid letzte Woche ist
gerade zu Ende da zaubert er plötzlich
eine Zusage Schwedens aus dem Hut ohne
deren Umsetzung die Türkei den
NATO-Beitritt nicht ratifizieren werde
73 Menschen Schweden hat uns das
Versprechen gegeben dass sie diese 73
Menschen ausliefern werden es
was haben die Regierungen von Schweden
und Finnland wirklich versprochen um den
Autokraten in der Allianz auf ihre Seite
zu holen im Memorandum dass die drei
Regierungen in Madrid unterzeichnen
heißt es Finnland und Schweden werden
die anhängigen Anträge der Türkei zur
Auslieferung von Terrorverdächtigen
zügig und gründlich bearbeiten von einer
konkreten Zahl will die schwedische
Außenministerin heute nichts wissen
wir werden dieses Memorandum vollständig
einhalten aber wie Sie sehen es werden
immer morandum keine Listen keine Zahlen
genannt und auch während unserer
Verhandlungen in Madrid wurden keine
Listen oder Zahlen erwähnt
eine Liste die es angeblich nicht gibt
auf der aber so berichten türkische
Medien auch sein Name stehen soll Bülent
kinnich es ist sagt der heute ein Test
nicht für Erdogan sondern für Schweden
ob es mit dem Druck eines NATO Landes
beugt
zurück nach Deutschland noch mal
Energien nochmal sorgen noch mal viel
Geld Hannah ja um die Gasversorger im
Notfall durch einen Schutzschirm retten
zu können hat die Bundesregierung heute
eine Reform des
energiesicherungsgesetzes beschlossen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck sprach
von einem vollen Arsenal der
Möglichkeiten und Valerie Haller
darunter auch die Option die hohen
Preise an die Verbraucher weiterzugeben
heißt das jetzt das Gas schon bei teurer
wird für alle teurer schon aber Ziel des
Schutzschirms ist es schon auch
drastische Preissprünge für den
Gaskunden erstmal zu verhindern darum
will die Bundesregierung die
gasvorsorger zunächst unterstützen die
Logik dahinter wenn ein großer
Energiekonzern wie Juniper Geld vom
Staat bekommt dann kann er seine Kunden
also die Stadtwerke weiter beliefern zu
den ausgemachten Preisen und damit wäre
dann erstmal allen geholfen nur geht
staatsrettung nun mal nicht unbefristet
und in einem nächsten Schritt könnte
beispielsweise eine sich um Lage kommen
die von allen Gaskunden zu tragen wäre
Gas würde dann vermutlich für jeden
deutlich teurer welche Maßnahmen sind
denn außerdem geplant also das Gesetz
soll auch Staatsbeteiligungen
vereinfachen was im Falle von uniper
durchaus vorstellbar wäre ein Versorger
dieser Größe der sollte einfach nicht
ins Straucheln kommen uniter beliefert
hunderte Stadtwerke also ein Unternehmen
auf das ist ankommt in der Energiekrise
des weiteren kann die Regierung laut
Gesetzentwurf auf Vorgaben zur
Raumtemperatur in Bürogebäuden machen
oder Gewerbe dazu verpflichten Gas durch
andere Brennstoffe zu ersetzen an der
Börse kursieren Rezessionsängste der DAX
fällt auf ein Jahrestief fast drei
Prozent Minus und auch der Euro verliert
gerade rasant an Wert gegenüber dem
Dollar ist er auf den tiefsten Stand
seit 20 Jahren gefallen und bis der Euro
mit dem Dollar gleich aufliegt ist es
wohl nur noch eine Frage der Zeit danke
Valerie nach Frankfurt
Italiens Regierung hat angesichts der
schwersten Dürre seit 70 Jahren den
Notstand in fünf nördlichen Regionen des
Landes ausgerufen der größte Fluss
Italiens der Po führt kaum noch Wasser
katastrophale ist das für die
Landwirtschaft mehr als ein Drittel der
italienischen Agrarproduktion ist laut
Bauernverband bedroht auch der Tiber in
Rom ist stellenweise nur noch ein
flaches Rinnsal und die Schifffahrt nur
eingeschränkt möglich
zum Tennis und einem packenden
Viertelfinale in Wimbledon bei dem
gleich zwei deutsche Tennisspielerinnen
um den Einzug ins Halbfinale gekämpft
haben
noch kann sie es nicht fassen Tatjana
Maria gewinnt das deutsch-deutsche
Viertelfinale gegen Jule Niemeyer die
zweifache Mutter setzt sich gegen die
zwölf Jahre jüngere Dortmunderin mit den
nötigen biss- und Willen durch nach
nervösem Auftakt bei dem Maria den
Bällen geradezu hinterherlaufen muss
findet sie im Verlauf immer besser ins
Match im zweiten Durchgang erkämpft sie
den Satzausgleich surfen volley exakte
Stopps aber auch eine gute Vorhand ihr
Rezept für den Sieg
vielleicht was meine Erfahrung dass
keine Ahnung aber ich meine ich habe
einfach nur weiter gekämpft bis zum Ende
und bin überglücklich dass das gewinnen
konnte nach zwei Stunden und 18 Minuten
verwandelt sie den ersten Matchball zum
4:662 und 7 zu 5 und spielt am
Donnerstag um den Einzug ins Endspiel
und jetzt begleiten wir hochbegabte
Menschen in ihrem Alltag IQ über 130 und
stellen fest auch sie und gerade sie
haben oft zu kämpfen 37 Grad schlauer
als der Rest der Welt gleich nach uns
wir alle können da noch viel lernen
damit sagen wir tschüss einen schönen
Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das Unglück vom
Wochenende in Südtirol zeigt dem ewigen
Eis in den Alpen geht es in diesem
Sommer dramatisch an die Substanz das
hat mehrere Gründe es gab im Winter
besonders auf der Alpen Südseite wenig
Regen und vor allem wenig Schnee
normalerweise schützt dieser die
Gletscher vor Sonneneinstrahlung Schnee
wirkt isolierend dazu kam im Frühjahr
der Saharastaub aus Nordafrika der sich
auf die Gletscheroberfläche legte diese
dunkle Schicht nimmt viel Sonnenlicht
auf und erwärmt das Eis das beschleunigt
die Schmelze weiter auch führen die
hohen Temperaturen in der Alpenregion
derzeit Lokal zu mehr Schmelzwasser und
da liegt die Gefahr es sammelt sich
Schmelzwasser unter und teilweise im Eis
an der Gletscher kann dadurch seinen
Halt am Felsen verlieren und Abrutschen
die Situation in den Alpen ist so
dramatisch wie nie experten vermuten
dass die Gletscher im Zuge der
Klimakrise in den nächsten 30 keine
Ahnung mehr als 50% zurückgehen werden
und der Sommer der hat gerade mal
angefangen wir schauen jetzt aufs Wetter
und in der Nacht gibt es im Norden etwas
Regen sonst klart es auf bei 8 bis 14
Grad und morgen im Tagesverlauf dann zum
Nachmittag vor allem von Norden her
Schauer und die können auch mal
kräftiger ausfallen ansonsten bleibt es
größtenteils trocken Temperaturen dazu
18 Grad ganz im Norden und 25 Grad im
Südosten die kommenden Tage am
Donnerstag gibt es kräftige shower und
Gewitter von Norden her bei 17 bis 25
Grad danach wieder trockener ein schöner
Abend